[Musique]
magdala a franchi la frontière par le
chemin rexam le 7 août dernier elle se
retrouve sous les tentes pendant quatre
jours à saint bernard de lacolle
sitôt arrivé à montréal elle partage un
appartement avec deux autres collègues
mais son souhait le plus cher est de
trouver du travail je veux voler de mes
propres ailes on n'aimerait pas vraiment
rester de l'assistanat tout
et bien son voeu a été exaucé deux fois
plutôt qu'une
le jour elle travaillait ce comptoir
alimentaire au chum
il ya le rapport avec les clients ici on
dans un hôpital donc ça peut être aussi
intéressant
elle a de la compassion est les connais
un petit peu le milieu puis nous on a
donné sa chance avec dallas qui on est
très satisfait de son travail et la nuit
elle est chef d'equipe dans une
résidence pour personnes âgées
mettant ainsi sa formation d'infirmière
à contribution elle est ici dès 23h à 7h
du matin c'est bien c'est au travail
umanis il faut aimer savoir et j'aime ça
elle a une expérience acquise la doua et
vient donc c'est en plus elle a fait sa
formation donc elle a tout tout ce qu'on
a besoin de cette issue est très
satisfaite
magdala travail donc 67 heures par
semaine mais elle attend toujours de
passer devant la commission de
l'immigration
on est à la troisième fois le de la date
d'audience
l'audience était prévue la dernière fois
pour le 9 mai une semaine avant donc
c'était on m'a dit que qu'ils ont envoyé
ça pour cause administratif
une telle issue son mari et ses huit
enfants sont restés en haïti
on n'est pas prévu d'être demandeur
d'asile et des réfugiés
sauf si le pays est en guerre quelque
chose comme ça mais demander l'asile on
n'est pas possible et cela et si c'était
quelque chose de planifier je joue est
venu avec toute ma famille parce que la
laisser mes enfants derrière comme ça la
dernière à cinq ans c'est difficile
dans ses temps libres elle trouve aussi
le moyen de faire du bénévolat
parce qu'elle est chrétienne
précise-t-elle bon il faut être graves
de la vie parce que tu sais moi
l'expérience mais parce que j'ai passé
toute ma vie à travailler dans
l'humanitaire
ce secteur si on n'est pas grave on ne
suffira pas ici catherine kovacs radio
canada montréal
[Musique]